Some say it’s an alien, others say a military
experiment.
It’s also been called a dinosaur, a humanoid,
a robot, and even the devil itself.
Earning its name from its favorite prey “the
goatsucker”el chupacabras, stalks the countryside
and cities alike.
Chupacabras are a popular folk legend but
not everyone knows there are two different
versions of the monster.
Reports of el chupacabras occur everywhere
from Puerto Rico, where it actually originated,
to Maine.
Whenever one is sighted or found dead, the
international press latches on to the story
with the same intensity as the bloodsucker
itself.
Some believe it is a freak of nature.
Others are convinced it was a culmination
of mass hysteria.
But it’s said to be a monster that doesn’t
normally hunt humans.
So why are we so afraid of it?
The first reports of el chupacabras are actually
relatively recent as monsters go.
It’s a modern monster, first appearing in
1995 in the Puerto Rican town of Canóvanas.
There were reports of the deaths of “dozens”
of farm animals whose blood had apparently
been sucked dry by small perforations in the
neck and abdomen.
It caused immediate panic.
No animal was safe.
Ducks, rabbits, chickens, pigs, and yes goats,
were all said to have been killed by a grotesque
creature.
In Puerto Rico, chupacabras are said to be
three to five feet tall with wings like a
bat, fangs, a hunched back, large black or
red eyes, and covered with either scales or
quills.
Some reports include tiny arms and the ability
to jump great distances.Others claim it has
spikes along its back and a long tongue.
For the residents of Canóvanas in 1995 this
terrifying monster was a real threat.
Their livestock were dying and people were
so scared, that guards were positioned to
protect what animals were left, children were
escorted to school, and some families even
abandoned their homes.
As local and national papers picked up the
story, reports increased across the island.
By April 1996, more than 2,000 animals had
fallen victim to el chupacabras.
At different times, Puerto Rico housed U.S.
military personnel.
This includes Fort Buchanan located less than
40 minutes from Canóvanas.
Rumors swirled that el chupacabras was an
escaped military experiment.
This is when things get more interesting.
Annddd political.
Mayor José Ramón “Chemo” Soto, who was
up for reelection in 1996, decided to take
matters into his own hands and protect the
people and animals of his town with a safari.
In October 1995, Soto organized 200 people,
including armed cops, and set out and catch
the monster.
Dude literally dragged a goat around in a
cage and carried a large crucifix.
The press dubbed him “Chemo Jones”
Soto also loved to give interviews, and when
the international, English-speaking press
heard of el chupacabras in late 1995, his
quotes appeared in The Washington Post, The
New York Times, and this fun one.
Soto wasn’t the only politician to address
el chupacabras.
The Puerto Rican government decided to step
in.
They were not only concerned for the people
and their livelihoods; they also recognized
the negative impact the monster could have
on tourism.
Biologists were brought in to find the scientific
explanation for the attacks.
Theories ranged from bats driven by drought
to seek new food sources, roving packs of
wild dogs, to escaped rhesus monkeys that
had been imported for scientific testing.
One zoologist believed the majority of the
attacks were caused by a spike in the mongoose
population.
Don’t let their cuteness fool you, those
things are nuts.
Fun fact: Even though Puerto Ricans are citizens
of the United States and must obey all of
its laws, they don’t have the right to vote
in the presidential election.
They’re asked to obey federal laws, but
have little power to change them.
Technically, Puerto Rico is a commonwealth
of the United States.
So Puerto Ricans — at least based on their
lack of voting rights — are outsiders in
their own country.
Which…just seems crazy to me.
What is this, Victorian England?
Despite all of this, or perhaps because of
it, El Chupacabras became a pop culture phenomenon.
For some Puerto Ricans, the monster became
an anti-hero, a monstrous symbol for their
own otherness in relation to the United States.
By the end of 1995, thousands of shirts were
printed with illustrations of chupacabras.
It inspired three songs, and a cocktail.
In the early 2000s, a different kind of chupacabra
emerged.
Reports from Mexico and the southwestern United
States described el chupacabras as a hairless,
gaunt animal walking on four legs—a vast
departure from the original Puerto Rican monster.
Unlike the Puerto Rican version, actual corpses
have been found.
Upon examination, these canine-looking creatures
always turn out to be coyotes, dogs, or raccoons
with genetic abnormalities or victims of mange.
An animal infected with mange has severe itching
and hair loss.
Some even have self-inflicted wounds from
scratching and chewing.
In advanced cases, the skin of the animal
will become thicker and darker in color, and
their body may be emaciated.
All of these symptoms can explain the chupacabras
appearance.
Because this “chupacabra” is based on
real world animals, it carries less cultural
significance than it’s Puerto Rican cousin.
The unique political status of Puerto Rico
helped to shape the el chupacabras myth.
It became a symbol of cultural otherness,
and the mystery surrounding its origin emphasized
how those in power can control information.
One thing both myths have in common, is that
real animals are actually dying.
For farmers and rural citizens, the threat
to their livelihoods is a huge, very real
problem.
Monster mythologies are typically thought
of as ancient tales told long ago.
But el chupacabras shows us that these stories
can arise today.
They highlight our fascination with trying
to explain the unexplained, and allow us to
tell our cultural histories by merging fact
and fiction.
I can’t help but wonder, what form will
the chupacabras take next?
Have you ever seen el chupacabras?
Let me know in the comments.
And don’t forget to subscribe!